>> ♪ ♪
>> SMOLLETT WANTED THEM TO
ATTACK HIM AND ALSO STATED HE
WANTED THE BROTHERS TO CATCH HIS
ATTENTION BY CALLING HIM
[INAUDIBLE].
HE WANTED ONE TO PLACE A ROPE
AROUND HIS NECK AND POUR
GASOLINE ON HIM AND YELL THIS IS
MAGA COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THE COOK COUNT'S
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE LAID OUT IN
DETAIL SMOLLETT'S WRONGDOING.
DOES HE HAVE AN EVIDENCE?
WE WILL ASK HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
HE STAGED SOME OF THE MOST
FAMOUS DEFENSES IN LEGAL
HISTORY.
THE O.J. CASE AND MANY OTHERS.
WHAT IS SMOLLETT'S DEFENSE HERE?
>> WELL, HIS DEFENSE IS THAT
NOBODY EVERY GETS PROSECUTED FOR
MAKING FALLS REPORTS.
REMEMBER TAWANA BRAWLEY THE
PEOPLE WHO DEFENDED HER WENT
FREE AND WENT ON TO POLITICAL
AND MEDIA CAREERS.
THERE ARE OTHER INSTANCES.
WE HAVE TO PRESUME EVERYBODY
INNOCENT.
IF THE FACTS ARE AS THE POLICE
SAY THEY ARE, IF PAYMENTS WERE
MADE AND A PLAN WAS HATCHED TO
PUT A ROPE AROUND THE NECK AND A
POLICE REPORT WAS FILED, THANE
THEN WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR A
SERIOUS CRIME.
I AM SURPRISED THEY CHARGED HIM
ONLY WITH DISTURBING THE PEACE.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> Laura: EVEN AS A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, I WAS A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY TOO, SHOULD
THIS MATTER HERE?
TO ME GIVEN THE TOXICITY OF THE
CHARGES AND THE HEAT THAT IS ON
CHICAGO AND THE RACE RELATIONS,
WE HEARD TWO WELL RESPECTED
PEOPLE FROM THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS HOT THERE.
TO SAY JUST PROBATION AND IT'S
NOT A BIG DEAL.
THAT SEEMS RIDICULOUS.
>> I AGREE.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CONTEXT
AND THE PRESSURES ON THE CITY
AND IN THE END, I DO THINK A
CASE LIKE THIS, IF THE EVIDENCE
IS OVERWHELMING AS IT LOOKS LIKE
IT IS, THERE WILL BE SOME KIND
OF A PLEA BARGAIN.
HE WILL ADMIT IT AND APOLOGIZED
AND DO COMMUNITY SERVICE.
I AGREE.
I THINK PEOPLE WHO MAKE FALSE
REPORTS OUGHT TO GO TO JAIL.
IN THE BIBLE IF YOU FALSELY
ACCUSED SOMEONE, YOU GET THE
PENALTY THE PERSON WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN HAD THE ACCUSATION BEEN
TRUE.
IF THESE PEOPLE ATTACKED HIM IN
THIS RACIST WAY AND PUT A NOOSE
AROUND HIS NECK, THEY WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN YEARS IN JAIL.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE BIBLE, THIS
GUY OUGHT TO GET THE SAME
PENALTY THAT HE FALSELY ACCUSED
OTHER PEOPLE OF GETTING.
WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THE
CASE.
WERE THESE PEOPLE GOING TO TAKE
THE RAP OR GO TO JAIL?
>> Laura: APPARENTLY $3500 IS
NOT ENOUGH.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT HAS TO PAY MORE.
THEY WILL SING LIKE CANNARY
THEY WILL SING LIKE CANNAIES
AND THEY GET AN EXTRA $500.
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS ARE SAYING
HE IS BEING FRAMED AND IT'S
UNFAIR.
MARK GERAGOS JOINED THE TEAM.
HE WAS ON CNN AND HE IS TIPPING
THEIR HAND ON THE DEFENSE.
YOUR FRIEND BRANSON FROM L.A.
CHIMES IN.
>> SOMEBODY TWEETED YESTERDAY OR
THE DAY BEFORE AND IT MADE
SENSE.
THIS IS A POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT
HAS HAD SOME ISSUES.
>> I THINK THERE ARE ISSUES WITH
THE CHICAGO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AS THE GENERAL PROPOSITION,
WHETHER THEY TREATED PEOPLE OF
COLOR FAIRLY.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF DOING AN INVESTIGATION
WITHOUT ANY DIFFICULT ISSUES
ARISING.
>> Laura: NOW IT'S THE CHICAGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT IS CORRUPT.
SO JUSSIE SMOLLETT IS INNOCENT.
>> IT'S MORE THAN CORRUPT.
THE SUGGESTION IS THEY ARE
RACISTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT CUTS.
LOOK, I NEVER CONDEMN A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY FOR TRYING TO BE
CREATIVE AND COME UP WITH ANY
PLAUSIBLE DEFENSE.
THAT'S WHAT THE 6th AMENDMENT TO